hey youtubers is charlie this is going
to be my episode 8 q a video I also
included a couple from the episode 9
trailer so just careful for spoilers for
everything that's happened on the show
so far the funny thing that just
happened is we got descriptions for the
last two episodes HBO initially refused
to release episode synopsises just to
prevent potential spoilers for getting
out but then little one sentence teasers
were released so the one sentence teaser
for episode 9 is terms of surrender are
rejected and accepted and then 4 episode
10 for the finale winds of winter Cersei
faces her trial and that is confirmed to
be 69 minutes which is about 15 minutes
longer than a normal episode so that's
an extra 15 minutes to make you crap
your pants going into season 7 because
what I think is going to happen is they
made some scenes a little bit longer
than they normally would have been like
Circe's trial is an extra-long scene
you'll see a couple of other characters
that are part of the big storyline to
wrap up running storylines like you'll
see Varys he'll show up again then you
have all a brand stuff that's going on
up in the north with the White Walkers
that'll probably be an extra-long scene
and then whatever is happening with
generics like if she actually does end
up setting sail for Westeros an
initiative to having just like an
amazing Cersei trial I can't wait to see
how that's gonna go down I definitely
made sure to add some questions of this
from that so here we go first question
Perry asks have we totally forgot about
the Tower of joy reveal no we have not
forgotten about it but it's kind of on
the back burner right now because we
have to get through this big battle of
the bastards episode the thing about the
Tower of joy reveal is I feel like
they're waiting to create the context
for why that reveal is necessary like
why it's so important that Jon Snow be
the son of lianas dark and Rhaegar
Targaryen and some of that might have to
do with what's going to be happening in
King's Landing because what I'm really
hoping is that Tommen is going to be
collateral damage from whatever Circe's
escape plan is from this big trial which
I made sure to address in a couple of
the questions that I picked a whole lot
of Cersei stuff we have to talk about
next question pratik asks what is the
rumor Circe was talking about so she was
talking to Kai burn about something that
he had his little birds investigating I
think that his little birds found more
wild fire I talked about it briefly in a
couple other videos but the Mad King
when he was getting ready to burn down
King's Landing with wildfire
hid a bunch of wildfire in those jars
all over the city so they never found it
all so I think the little birds just
found some which also gives you an idea
for why they chose to show that during
brands flashback I think they tried to
make brands flashbacks as awesome as it
was to see that Mad King flashback I
think they're trying to make all of
those relevant to all of the storylines
not just very specific moments brands
seeing things in the past as they happen
and that being foreshadowing for things
that'll be happening in the future also
giving him ideas about how to deal with
the White Walkers think about the way
Jamie was talking to Edmure about Cersei
seriously being so hardcore so imagine
if Cersei felt like she had no other
options she was backed into a corner
don't you think she would try to burn
down the red key for the great said
wherever the trial is going to take
place I think that will be the were crap
she's going to try and burn her problem
away but think about the collateral
damage that that would cause and
actually I made sure to address this in
a follow-up question about Jamie next
question bill asks Circe's wildfire will
raise the same feelings than Jamie that
led him to kill Ares yeah I totally
think that that could be a thing if
Cersei founds wildfire and she burns
down part of King's Landing Tommy could
be collateral damage reigniting those
feelings Jamie had about the Mad King
it's really hard to imagine Jamie being
a good person when he's with Cersei this
is just one of those things that could
drive them apart for good in the books
they've already been driven apart but
would it be amazing if Jamie turned out
to be the valent car the little brother
he was born after Cersei so even though
they're twins technically he is the
younger brother by a couple minutes
Cersei burning down part of King's
Landing Mad King style would definitely
be cause for him to take her down and
there's a big theme this season with
characters having their deeply held
beliefs shaken brand learning the truth
of the Tower of joy how his father
survived he thought his father was this
great honorable person with the only
reason he survived that Tower of joy
encounter was because he won in a very
dishonorable way so the last couple of
episodes Jamie seemed absolutely certain
of his belief in searcy don't be
surprised if she does something that
makes him question his belief in her
next question Ivan asks so who's the one
that says thousands of men don't have to
die and what does it mean when he says
only one of us so this is from the
episode 9 trailer it sounds like
on snow is going to Ramsey before the
battle starts and saying look we can do
this one on one and that would be like
the Honorable way to settle the dispute
that idea of Honor also ties back to
brand seeing his father win in a very
dishonorable way characters having honor
Jamie's honor being questioned at
Riverrun in the idea that Ramsey has no
honor which is probably why we here
Sansa saying you don't know Ramsey you
don't know what he's capable of Jon Snow
is a very honorable person you can
imagine he would honor typical rules of
engagement whereas Ramsey would win at
any cost so even if he were to enter
into a one-on-one with Jon Snow which I
don't know if that's going to be the
case or not because we see this big
battle so obviously we know it doesn't
go down that way but even if he were to
accept a one-on-one fight with Jon Snow
I don't think that he would honor the
terms of the agreement he would tell his
commanders you know attack anyway next
question kachou asks if the tully
soldiers would only obey the Lord of the
castle EDD mere why did they obey
blackfish to not do anything when the
phrase said that they would slit his
throat don't they owe a duty to save
their Lord and disobey orders to the
contrary so I think the idea behind that
is that the blackfish is just this very
respected military commander they know
he knows what's going on so I think
they're trusting him to a point when he
comes to the gate later though I think
that's where they draw the line where
he's standing there let me in I am The
Lord of the house you must let me in
whereas when the phrase had him strung
up earlier and were threatening to kill
him had Edmure given them a command as
the Lord of the house they might have
disobeyed the blackfish next question
for he nests what do you think Aria
meant when she talked about going to the
west of Westeros well there's a lot of
the known world that George are Martin
hasn't explored yet there's a southern
continent we haven't seen yet but he's
talked about she wasn't talking about
that if you're looking at a flat version
of the map even if you traveled off the
left edge of it you wouldn't arrive back
around on the far side of the east it's
not like a map of the earth when it's
laid out flat this is only called the
known world so she's talking about going
into the unknown lands if you remember
the end of the lord of the rings were
they sail away from Middle Earth and go
to valinor that's kind of like what Aria
is talking about she's gonna go to some
mythical place that we haven't seen yet
interestingly enough you're on Greyjoy
who we haven't seen in a while on the
show has sailed around most of the known
world he's boasted that he's been all
over the world so he actually probably
could
tell you what's west of Westeros you
have to remember Aria talked about all
that before she decided to go home so
she's going back to Westeros now next
question arises asks do you think the
jack ins intentions were not to teach
Arya to become a faceless person but to
become herself once again after living
years hiding her identity he seemed
pretty pleased with the outcome of what
happened no I don't think that was his
primary intention I think he really did
think that she had potential to become a
good faceless man but the resolution to
that I think is where the TV show
differs greatly from the books the way
the books talk about the faceless men's
organization the house of black and
white is it's not an organization that
you can just up and quit so in the books
in order for Aria to go home she might
have to kill a lot more people inside
the house of black and white but because
Jack and is the combination of a couple
different book characters my takeaway
was that he was pleasantly surprised
like okay you still have potential even
if it's not as a faceless person so I
think everything he did was intended to
help her become a faceless person but
because of some of the story issues that
TV show arias storyline has had I
wouldn't be surprised if they use this
completely circuitous route for jackin
to be like the power was within you the
whole time that's like the really cliche
moment where a character goes through a
big lesson and then they find out the
power was within them the whole time
next question those darkness asks do you
think we're going to see a sansa Arya
reunion this season it depends on how
much you believe in the mass transit
theory of Game of Thrones in the TV show
just you know characters moving around
way faster than they would in the books
I think they will meet up again but the
TV show has been really inconsistent
with the speed at which characters move
so like little finger moves really fast
all the time but then you have Brean and
Podrick that move really fast in some
episodes and really slow in other
episodes so just too inconsistent to
predict because normally it would take
REO weeks to get back to Winterfell if
that's where she was going but i do
think she's headed in that direction and
i do think that she will see sonsa again
we'll see more stark reunions eventually
next question esteban asks how can John
defeat Ramsey well I think the idea is
is that he can't defeat Ramsey he's
going to need little finger style need
other people's help there's a lot of him
being overconfident in that episode 9
trailer we've been in the north we face
much much worse he's talking about the
White Walkers and he's not wrong the
white
walkers are definitely worse than Ramsey
but I think Sansa is just cautioning him
saying that Ramsey is more unpredictable
than the night's king don't you love
that idea the night's king has more
honor in battle than Ramsay snow does
Ramsey's unpredictability in lack of
otter makes him just as bad as the night
King next question large asks Ferris
leaves just before the Masters arrive
coincidence i think not yeah there's a
lot of people wondering if Varys is
secretly the harpy and that's why he
left I think the explanation is just a
little simpler if we've learned anything
from all the theories that the show is
taken a dump on is that usually the
explanation of the plot and the reasons
characters do things or ways simpler and
even in Arya's case her actions are
wildly inconsistent with previous
episodes so sometimes the show just
derps that way so i think what Veras is
doing is exactly what he says he's going
to secure loyalty in Westeros he wants
to find houses that will be loyal to
Daenerys and for those of you that have
read the books there is a very special
Varys moment at the end that might be
given to another character though I
don't think he's specifically going back
to King's Landing but i do think we'll
see some virus book stuff even if that
plot line is given to another character
and i don't think that anything that
Varys has done has been to hurt tenaris
he's part of the Targaryen restoration
he thinks the realm needs tenaris so
he's going to do everything he can to
help her thank you everyone for so many
questions though there's always a ton of
fun to do they'll be a couple extra
videos just because we're moving closer
to the finale they'll be at least one
more bonus video before my episode 9
video on Sunday congratulations to this
week's giveaway winner Albert Wesker you
win a twenty-dollar amazon gift card be
sure to private message me on the back
end of my channel so i can get your
contact details that's just on the about
page so if there's any special bonus
videos that you want to request the next
couple days just leave them below in the
comments while you guys wait for my next
video to post you can click here for my
episode 9 trailer video and you can
click here for my episode 8 video thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you